by the misconceptions about me really
and I've got none for that one think
about politics though nowadays is that
it basically you just people tend to get
very extreme view of their political
leaders because it's just politics is
conducted in a very very hyperbolic way
you know so I mean I come here and read
some what's written about President
Obama at whether you agree with what
disagree movie it's just kind of wild
you know so I don't I think
misconceptions about i think the single
hardest thing about today's politics is
to speak as a politician unmediated to
people I'm speaking to you unmediated so
you can make up your mind about what I'm
saying I want I'm like or whatever but
in that in today's world it's incredibly
difficult to have that conversation
unmediated you know I don't know why
your media here but I mean increasingly
and certainly in the UK but also in the
media rest of Europe people actually
don't hear a lot of what the politicians
say they hear somebody interpreting what
they've said and that interpretation is
in order to make an impact usually as
sort of sensational as possible so it's
there's a anyway it's not quite an
answer to a question but there it is